hey guys justin and chris here with AGS
breakdown what we're talking about is
borderlands the whole bunch of rumors
and craziness circulating yesterday but
you have the the actual details you've
seen the game can you confirm
Borderlands 3 on ps4 and xbox one
finally no oh not even a little bit it's
not Borderlands 3 it is the third
Borderlands game it's called Borderlands
the pre-sequel but it's called the
pre-sequel it's called the pre-sequel
because it's borderline to the sequel
takes place before board on it soon but
after borderlines one so it's like cramp
right in the middle there
chronologically speaking though it does
run on the borderlands 2 engine so it
still looks pretty nice I saw a game
demo in action I was on the pc version
so we've had all that physics stuff
going but it's coming out for the pc the
xbox 360 and the playstation 3 no
next-gen borderlands confirmed at all
well that that is a surprising but that
is what we heard from from these rumors
even though it's not next-gen what did
you see you did is it something that's
exciting is it gonna be something that
you want to play as a board of lines fan
or is this just the same old table if
you want more borderlands it's more
borderlands yeah so I mean it's the same
it's the same format you've got the Ford
for new vault hunters and you know
you're working for handsome Jack before
he becomes the sort of full-blown super
villain that he is Oh in Borderlands 2
hey that's just what they told me and I
just understood you know the messenger
here but you know from the game demo to
your computer screen uh takes place on
the moon and Dora's moon which as your
call is a little bit broken up and
there's like that giant H Hyperion space
station shooting big space lasers into
it handsome jack is trying to like it's
part of his rise to power part of his
like you know origin story I guess if
you will die like the character handsome
Jack so much and so did a bunch of you
guys that he's back what about Matt
traffic face is there gonna be a clap
clap trap is my favorite character yeah
is he in the game oh yeah big time he is
actually one of the playable vault
hunters and uh this is a question I
asked her in the demo was claptrap I
mean like this toll in her too so will
his point of view be like odd job style
from gold and I and be like very low
ground yes good as a short guy that's
the kind of advantage that I look for
uh-huh some being set on the moon though
is there it I heard there were some
rumors about oxygen playing some kind of
weird role in this hat is that true how
does that work yeah so there's an oxygen
meter now that accompanies your health
and shield meter and it slowly decreases
whenever you're outside in a zero
atmosphere environment low gravity so
like Ordonez kind of has floaty jumps
now they're even floaty er but yeah you
gotta you have this oxygen meter soul
these declines but like if you go inside
where there's atmosphere it replenishes
if you find a luna bowl oxygen chunk
from a loop chest yo word punish it
there are also stations you can activate
creates this kind of atmosphere dome
where your oxygen won't decrease but
also a bunch of enemies are gonna come
running at you and shoot you and stuff
in the true Borderlands fashion also
remove technology so like I guess I
guess you like your jetpack you kind of
have a little bit of a jetpack they said
they said it's like you can spend 02 to
do a double jump although what I saw was
not like jump jump it was more like jump
and then glide like a really tongue and
then we've all had a double jump
mechanic it's something similar to that
I did we didn't see that in action but
they might not have shown the double
jump it was a very limited demo up like
also there's a tumble maneuver like a
dodge out of the way kind of thing but
they didn't show that that's gonna cost
oxygen but they did show was the ground
pound which every character can do now
because you can jump so high it's plenty
space for you to then come back down
ground pound and you can get like like a
shield kit you can get an 02 kit or an
oz kit they're calling it that will like
imbue that with elemental damage or
stuff like that of course there's four
new characters claptrap is one of them
we don't know what his ability is it
they didn't talk about him much nisha
the law bringer she was a character in
borderlands 2 the sheriff of lynch would
don't know much about her Wilhelm is
this little wolverine looking guy who's
like actually like almost fully half
machine half man or mostly machine man
boss robot in Borderlands 2 you fight
him very early on he was in the demo but
the character that they played with was
Athena the gladiator and her active
skill is like a captain america shield
like hold that thing up it absorbs all
damaging coming from the front and then
at the end she throws it out beans an
enemy they explode like a good tie-in
with the Winter Soldier which is out in
theaters now you know capitalize on that
shield throwing genre which is real hot
right now any other cool new moon
weapons earth yes cryo ammo one of the
big things that Randy Pitchford was very
excited about freeze guns so it's a new
elemental damage and it does that thing
that you want to freeze gun to do free
the enemy in a block of ice and then you
shatter them and then because it's low
gravity the you know it doesn't all just
crumble to the ground it kind of like
floats away and you see like meat chunks
inside of the ice chunks and there's
just and like you know when there's no
atmosphere also your loop will float
away and it'll come back down eventually
cuz there's some gravity but you know
they're getting playful with the the
moon setting it's being developed by 2k
Australia which is you know in
conjunction with gearbox software and
those guys I've worked a bunch on
Bioshock games but now they're really
putting a lot of aldi humor I guess in
two more lines to our alliance the
pre-sequel i should say give me a lot of
Ned Kelly jokes I don't know who that is
so I mean I guess when he said there was
no water line 3 that's true this is not
actually Borderlands 3 gearbox might
still have something in the works though
and they've definitely teased a a
next-gen reveal coming at some point
yeah they said that they've got a new IP
in the works at gearbox software and
then they're doing borderlands 2 stuff
as well and they were you know obviously
everyone wants to know is this
borderline 3 isn't coming to next-gen
favorites they were sort of adamant to
say look people want more borderlands
but all those people play border lines
on the pc 2 360 2 ps3 like a fraction of
them have next-gen systems the install
base just you know it's not there yet so
they're they're like going for one more
round of borderlands on lachen I'm sure
we'll see it on next-gen sometime in the
future but no announcements for that so
when our people are actually going to be
able to play this game slated for the
fall actually so just a few months away
we'll probably see more of it at e3
they're showing it off at PAX East this
weekend but we've pretty much already
seen all that stuff and if you want to
know more about it I've got a pretty
extensive written preview up so there's
a lot more detail on different weapon
types and
how afina the character seems to play
what kind of strategies and skills you
can unlock through her various skill
trees so be sure to check that out if
you want to read more or see more about
the borderlands universe go ahead and
check out gamespot com